hi I'm Matt Greene and I'm Rick
Bickerstaff and the title of our talk is
authentic computational thinking and a
project-based public high school and
we're going to share with you how we use
Wolfram language to get after your
computational thinking with mathematics
and computer science in our school we're
gonna spend some time this afternoon
with you talking about our experience
with computational thinking in our
project-based public high school in
Spokane Washington I want to talk about
four things today they're not of equal
weight we're gonna spend most of our
time on the third one we're going to
talk first briefly about how we view
computational thinking we're gonna talk
a little bit about us and our school
we're going to talk about how we saw and
in some cases didn't see computational
thinking happen with the Wolfram
language in our school and then we're
gonna talk about where we're going next
so first I'll start by talking a little
bit about how we see computational
thinking as you may know there's some
conversation out there about what
actually is computational thinking
so we've distilled it down to this we
want students to use computation to
think in new ways and we're attempting
to align ourselves with a man who gave
us that fat phrase computational
thinking see more pepper so a couple
salient quotes from him that absolutely
are the language we're speaking he said
the goal is to use computational
thinking to forge ideas and we agree
with him when he said his central focus
is not on the machine but on the mind so
in the examples we share with you today
this is really about how students are
learning to think computationally we are
processing nerds we're gonna get into
how are they thinking how do we know how
do we take them to the next step and
we're really excited about what the
Wolfram language has allowed us to do as
educators to get inside our students
heads so you're going to hear some
excitement from us today
so first of all a little bit about our
school as matt said we're from Spokane
Washington east side of the state we are
one of three high schools in this
particular district we're not the
largest district in this in the city of
Spokane that's the second largest three
high schools we are the third we are a
non traditional high school no bells no
whistles no classrooms we teach in a
collaborative manner where Matt and I
are teaching partners and we view
ourselves not as teachers with our
students but collaborators we have a
wide spectrum of socio-economic
background with our students we have
students who come from the wealthiest
families of Spokane and we have students
who sleep in their cars the night before
we have a great diversity probably more
socioeconomic average than even our
district has so we're not a magnet
school
we are project-based entrepreneurship
and stem focused and our students have a
one-to-one laptop ratio so when they
walk in they're handed an Apple laptop
with full access to the Internet 24
hours a day seven days a week that's
their knowledge base quite unique as a
school when it comes to this
there's none other like school like this
in Spokane no public school like this in
Spokane we struggle to find other public
schools like this in the country as a
matter of fact especially being public
so to give you some background we want
to tell you a little bit about our
journey I'm in my third year of teaching
high school mathematics Matt is in your
14th or so year it's matter fact he's
one of my former students we taught
together at a school I spent 23 years at
in Spokane it was in the other district
that's the large district school about
2,200 students traditional school and
when Matt was available to be a teacher
I kind of recruited him and together we
taught at that school we both been
department chairs at that place I went
on to become a district coordinator in
the larger district in our city I said
so I said I spent five years an
administrator working with teachers and
curriculum at the high school in college
and at the national level also it was
during this time where Matt and I
together were exploring with ideas that
might push the boundaries of what
happens in a traditional classroom and
probably the biggest frustration we had
is we really were trying to get to true
problem-solving with our students in
math they walk into our class at nine
o'clock in the morning leaving the
English class and in 52 minutes we were
ticket to and thinking deeply about
solving real problems in thinking
mathematically
we found it very challenging it was our
passion to work on this and we pushed
and we pushed and pushed Matt had an
opportunity to move to a new setting
where that might a little more freedom
and that's what River Point Academy at
that time I was actually working in a
local university in their math
departments and I was actually teaching
a math class
at that school as on staff at this
university at that time at River Point
Academy our school had a pullout model
for mathematics and that is River Point
Academy is an interdisciplinary approach
to curriculum they don't go to English
class they don't go to science class
they were working on it all day all
along all together except for one class
and that of course is math so River
Point Academy was started it didn't want
to be that way but they couldn't figure
out how to do it other ways they've
studied schools around the country who
else is doing this differently and came
up quite short so at that time I was
teaching a precalculus class from
University getting students college
credit whether there we had a pullout
model in mathematics for verba Point
Academy I then had an opportunity to
move to River one academy as a teacher
and then Matt and I are now back
together again in that location and we
put our brains together so we have to do
this differently how can we have a
school where the mathematics is
integrated into everything they do
mathematics and computer science
integrated that's what we want that is
our ultimate goal and we're not there
yet but that's our ultimate goal so we
went to our staff and said can we take
over mathematics and computer science in
this school will work with all ninth
through 12th graders our school has
about 160 students will work with all of
them we just want to work on the math
tutor science because we see math
computer science as the same they have
different skill sets yes but when you
talk about higher level processing
skills those are the same whether you're
thinking about it whether you're
actively writing code or actively trying
to solve a problem purely in mathematics
the same part of your brain is active
and we believe in that so we see
mathematics and computers as the same
we're trying to help our community which
is a very conservative community see
them the same is a challenge for us so
our goal was to move in that direction
and that brings us to the beginning of
last year and at that point we want to
say how can we get about doing this and
we decided as we as we talked about
doing this is we believe that that can
occur when the following has happened
students experience balance and
mathematical practice and skills there
has to be about
there we're a very skilled driven
mathematical society especially in
Spokane I've been in arguments with
school board members over that idea we
also want to make sure that students
have access to professional tools and
students solve real problems not just
exercises that math problem we solve in
52 minutes is not a problem it's just an
exercise can we get to real problems
that was our goal we actually wanted to
tackle all three of those in the first
year we got kicked in the tail again as
we have for all of our career Oh too
much to bite off so it turns out that we
actually end up tackling the first to
last year gained a lot of learning and
we're actually working on the third one
this year we're going to share all those
details with you so in that one of the
first things the first year's students
experience balance and mathematical
practice and skills if you're not
familiar with the Common Core State
Standards in the United States we have a
set of standards they were developed by
the states not the federal government in
all the states that hey let's get
together what makes good learning in
mathematics for students to be in k-12
moving into post k12 experiences there's
two sets there's the core and that is
what skills should they have and then
what thinking skills should they have
what processes should they have the
processes are called the standards for
mathematical practice and simply said
when students are engaged in the
practices of mathematical practice
standards for mathematical practice you
are seeing young mathematicians think
like Mack mathematician they're acting
like mathematicians there are eight of
those standards the skills are the easy
ones to get out we all know that gosh
your mind we actually have Khan Academy
doing that for us because we can do that
Siri does it really well also they're
important but we wanted our energy
around the mathematical practice we
focused on two of them and the reason we
focused on these two look for and make
use of structure and Express regular
repeated reasoning we focused on those
two out of the eight because when Matt
and I look at mathematics and you step
far enough back it seems to be three big
ideas number K four focuses on number
after K four you start moving into
abstraction equality really starts to
play a significant role as you move into
abstraction equality it's around
equality and rate of change k12
mathematics can kind of fall with those
three big headers number equality rate
of change these mathematical product
focus on equality and that's what we
wanted to watch we want to say well
students will students if they're
engaged the mathematical standards can
they get at that at those two by writing
code that was our question we wanted to
know more about that so we were looking
over similar that was one of our guiding
questions when it comes to that access
to professional tools we thought we have
Khan Academy to help us with their
skills what will we have students do to
engage in higher level thinking because
we don't stand in front our students and
talk that's not what we do we stand
beside them they're working all day long
and it didn't take long for us to fall
on Wolfram language we thought this is
the ticket the note the notebook where
they can do mathematics think
computationally write code all thats in
a notebook makes a lot of sense so we
launched with Mathematica Wolfram
language Matt contacted Wolfram we've
got some pricing we have it in all of
our students hands that's the tool we
want that's the professional tool we put
in our students hands to think this way
and so the guiding questions we have is
is well from language accessible to all
students that's all students not just
most of them but all of them that's what
we're after and we also want to see what
effect that would have on persevering
through difficult situations that's also
one of the mathematical practices will
they persevere will it help or will it
shut them down
that was our guiding questions to this
so those are the first two that we
really focused on last year it turns out
and what we did is we we created some
activities for them to engage in and
while they're engaged in those we looked
over the shoulders and look specifically
at those ideas those guiding questions
are they doing those things so some of
the things we did we did a couple things
we created some activities for them in
which students could engage in the
Wolfram language and you'll recognize
these they're right out of the online
notebook and the things that we started
to see you or these students are very
concrete when we had them start plotting
and making working with lists and we
wanted them to act on a list what they
wanted to do is just write out the list
oh the list of three times the numbers
one through ten I'll just write in three
six I'll just do that can they step to
that level of abstraction to where they
seal it the idea of range ten is
actually playing the role as a list
that's a step in abstraction it was
fascinating to watch them move toward
that step can they see the equality
between what
ten does and what the list it does it's
making that's a big step for them but
that was some of our introductory things
we're working on them with and then
moving past that this is just more
evolution we wanted to see can they go
from range into table that was really
hard for them they wanted to stay with
the range because they were comfortable
that he became concrete to them so we
asked him to do more complicated things
and introduce him the idea of table I
didn't wanna let go of range they kept
trying to do with table excuse me they
might let go range so I kept trying to
do it for Ange we wanted them to move in
a table so their first steps in a table
were actually quite archaic and they
looked a lot like range could we get
them to step beyond that and move into
what table can do with this functional
power and as we watch them do that we
don't tell them how to do it we just
watch and see what things that are doing
are they engaging in it are they
persevering are they seeing the
connections to equality as they do that
and we saw that they were all the
different rates but they were reaching
these things and this was given to most
of our students they had one of these
one of these a week a week to do and
they remember there were several and
each one of them continuing further more
work the table and this was fascinating
could they start to see table as a
function with a domain that was very
abstract for them that now what they're
seeing is something it's equivalent to
the list and it generates the list and
you can act on that list can you see it
as a generator when it comes to that and
can you do things with it and when they
did this and they slowly got there and
they got to this point we asked them to
start doing things with the list they
made like making list plots and then
what they found out was that's too much
to write if I just called the table
something like Dave I can just do a list
pot on Dave
once again equality they're seeing these
as equivalent forms and this is
something that we were seeing in
students naturally going toward and
using effectively that we weren't seeing
before before we were doing this with
Wolfram language in the years we taught
at the high school together we weren't
seeing these things the other thing that
showed up is we watch over their
shoulder about do they know where the
brackets go does the bracket go there or
does it go there and to watch them the
quick response from what from language
saying hey it's not giving you what you
want because they knew what they were
supposed to get and I'm not getting it
why and
to manipulate the bracket once again how
does the structure work what's happening
in that so we were rare we never told
how to do any of this we just patiently
bit her lips and watched and saw where
they were going with this information
but it's fascinating to see and once
again the focus on equality do they see
these as equivalent forms and that
feedback loop is so fascinating like we
said we're processed nerds right so
trying to not jump in as they're working
on something and they're doing it very
inefficiently and we have to just say
that from the top if our value is
efficiency first we lose learning
relearning is inefficient it's messy
it's a problematic so as teachers we
have to have the courage to kind of go
okay I could help you do that and we
could be done in five seconds but that
actually takes the learning from you
watching them struggle and make these
connections and we would share with each
other these stories about all Billy
today you should have seen it he put his
right bracket following the second
parameter because we knew that that was
an indicator of moving up these levels
of abstraction
it got us really excited as Rick
mentioned from the top we're not where
we want to be yet we're going to talk to
you a little bit with our time remaining
about next year but one more thing
before we get there before we get to
this notion of students solving real
problems and not just playing with
exercises the examples rick has showed
you they are academic exercises they're
from the elementary introduction to the
Wolfram language which by the way is
flippin fantastic it's I mean it should
be anybody's used it yeah obviously it
is we had to spend a couple weeks making
our own problems of the week which was
super hard and not very good and we're
like why don't we not just use what
exists so we had to learn that one the
hard way yeah we're going to show you
some other academic exercises but these
were intended for students who looked at
this step-by-step process and were bored
they were not interested in being
brought step-by-step through these
things so for these students and we made
all these options available to the whole
student body at anytime if you wanted to
not do the problem of the week this week
and join our project euler conversation
you were welcome to do that we wanted
them to have the freedom to choose I
think I might be ready for that
so project Euler if you're not familiar
is a set of mathematical exercises that
are computationally difficult so the
goal is to write code to solve these
math problems there are academic
exercises but they're interesting
puzzles
and the unifying factor for this small
group it was about 15 kids that kind of
grow and shrink in size throughout the
year the unifying factor was curiosity
they saw these as puddles puzzles and
they weren't held back by the fact they
did not understand how to use the
Wolfram language we tied into that
curiosity and use that as a way to get
them playing with the Wolfram language
so we're going to show you a couple
examples and again these are not
efficient solutions and that's not the
point
right efficiency will come we trust that
that's not our role as k12 math and
computer science educators is to get you
to be amazingly efficient our goal is to
get you to think about your thinking and
to know how to improve your processes so
one of these is from Quinn pretty
straightforward problem actually give
you the formulas for how to find
triangle triangular pentagonal and
hexagonal numbers you can see Quinn
wrote three functions for that and then
what's interesting about this if you
look at Quinn's code and we'd encourage
you this is unpassable if you want to
play with this if you pull the timing
statement off of here and look at the
outputs from his three try pent and hex
functions here is his combination of a
four loop and then the sow and reap
allows Quinn to peek into what's
happening in the four loop and that was
very very important for Quinn who was a
fast learner but was a new programmer
the year before he came to us he'd had
some experience in unity before he came
to us never not touched Mathematica he
needed to see what was happening so
those outputs were really essential for
him I don't think that's an efficient
use of those things but it didn't matter
because it made sense to him it's the
same argument that I make I made it
through my undergraduate math degree
only solving systems by substitution I
would go out of my way to algebra
algebraically rearrange something
because I was confident with that tool
it's very similar to what we see these
kids doing next example is Jenna and her
output is even more verbose she has less
experience than Quinn even hadn't
actually programmed much before she came
to us this problem is very interesting
convert the digits into actually written
words and there's a function in
Mathematica of course called integer
name which does this but there's a
problem
the
Matt of those numbers is different than
the expectation of format for the
project Euler problem particularly the -
integer name produces these long names
like 243 and if it's a hyphen in there
but you can't have the - if you're going
to submit your answer because it's going
to get your character count off when you
submit it to project Euler so Jenna as
you see looking through her work used
integer name in certain sub cases and
again you see her output because she
needed this as part of her development
to see is this working is this making
sense and then other places where
integer name didn't serve her like here
for decade she created some end arounds
so again very inefficient but some
beautiful thinking here and she was a
very very very proud of this work she'd
been attending all first semester hadn't
figured one out yet and got this one so
when we asked her coming to the
conference would you share with us some
stuff you've done
she said I'd love to share this one
because she's proud of her work so to
summarize real quick we're almost out of
time let's revisit our three guiding
questions for year 1 before we talk
about year 2 we wanted to know can
students actually engage is our thinking
that the kind of thinking in writing
code and doing mathematics these
mathematical practices can you actually
engage in that as a student by writing
code we believe the answer is very
clearly yes we believe that it is
accessible to all students this notion
of professional tools is what our school
is built on we have laser cutters CNC
machines 3d printers the best
professional software because we want
you using the professional tools from
the very beginning that is crucial for
you and your status as a learner so was
wool from one of those tools that was
accessible oh my goodness yes and then
will we see perseverance will they
actually continue to persist there's a
few quotes I skipped for sake of time
you can look at them one of our favorite
situations that happened a lot was you
we're in an old motorcycle shop our
school so across the room over there
you'll hear a kid exclaim you'll kind of
wander over what's wrong and this
happened on a number of occasions I just
can't figure this out one exercise on
elementary introduction problem set and
we would kind of say well maybe you
should just take a little break
and they look at you like you're crazy I
can't take a break I'm frustrated
because I can't figure this out so
they're frustrated and because they're
frustrated and emotionally invested they
refuse to quit that bird called that
hard fun right it's hard and it's fun at
the same time and part of the reason
it's fun is because it's hard we're
seeing that happen across ability levels
in our school and that gets us so
excited about what next year this year
gonna look labor giddy the first time we
heard that and we kept hearing it that
was really exciting it was a common
theme so I think we have 30 seconds to
talk about this year so Matt I get bored
very easily we said what's the next step
for this we want to get true
problem-solving so we went back to the
staff and said you know we think we
should have a class called comp lab
computational laboratory and in that we
want students thinking deeply about data
so we have actually created a course and
to get to right to the point is we want
students to be a develop argument be
consumers and receivers a argument
supported through data and that's our
current work so it's around rhetoric as
you're engage is an argument can you
support it with data and that's we're
knee-deep into it right now one of our
customers is sitting here in the thanks
for being here Mack and those are the
things we're taking on because these
should this should lead to deep
problem-solving yeah and we want them
engaged with data so we're actively
using the Wolfram language in that
course at the same time so more to learn
this year yeah we hope to be able to
come back and tell you more about what
happens this year so we have five
minutes for Q&A if you have anything
you'd like to ask or talk about we would
love some interaction yes
yes just had a board member who believed
that we should have very specific
algorithms for doing mathematics and
that's it and that's the first focus if
they can't do that they can't do
anything else
and I just completely disagree to them I
live in a very conservative community
very supportive education in Washington
State supports education very well but
we didn't see eye to eye on that I was a
I was a curriculum coordinator at the
time and just said well we're not gonna
do it that way we're just not gonna and
I know you could fire me but I just
can't I can't come to work every day and
other we're only gonna focus on
algorithms which is really important but
it can't be our only focus yeah we
weren't running together to I'd try to
establish a relationship so I can take
that one for the problem of the week
track the kids who wanted the
foundational approach we really leverage
the fact that there was expected output
and so kid by kid and our environment
really allows us to do this we really
individualize the experience and as we
build relationship with the kid this
kid's gonna need a different thing than
this kid and so if this student is
really struggling and needs us to step
in there were times where what we would
do if Rick was a student and I was the
teacher he'd be on his laptop in
mathematica I'd be on my laptop because
again we're not trying to take the tool
out of their hands but we would say can
we think together so we would do some
thinking and they would watch us writing
some code that was a huge AHA for us so
we got to come to the conference last
year watching experts write code in
front of us it was incredible another
thing we didn't even talk about was when
students made that shift to thinking
functionally where they build something
from the inside out I mean those are big
days like we're like huh
running across the room to high-five
each other because like they're doing
composition composition so there's not a
clear answer because it's totally
individualized to the student but there
are times where it's developmentally
appropriate for us to say what can I
show you something and sometimes to
where like we talked about switching
from range to table we had to pry range
out of their hands because they had come
to depend on that tool so much that
we're saying hey this tool is even
better but they didn't want to get rid
of range because they were comfortable
with it and we had an example up there
where it was two n plus one and it
produced
the set they wanted and then we looked
at the graph and we said then we just
has a question like well if that makes
one odds what if it was negative one and
you just watch them think and then they
go right to Mathematica I think we type
it in what is - hey works so they're
able to quickly see some of those
equivalences that they that we struggle
to see in our classrooms other otherwise
they looked at the idea of y equals MX
plus B quite differently and much more
openly as a tool for equivalence in math
thank you yeah I think if we can't
please correct me on this Rick if I say
this we're home okay but I think because
of our shared experience we were careful
to not expect too much because we've had
a variety of experiences where we think
it's reasonable we find out oh no that
wasn't so really when we say we think
this should happen we're wondering if it
will we really didn't know and the
reason we're doing what we're doing in
year two is because of how it went in
year one so for the same question if you
want to know well what comes after year
two well it depends on how far we see
the students getting with it's Stevens
computational X right we just want to
put a computational glasses on and look
at whatever you're interested in and see
what you can do with that with this tool
and now that we know it yeah that's why
it's important for us in the beginning
to identify guiding questions identify
the mathematical practice so we stayed
focus almost like a case study we didn't
want to be distracted by things that we
weren't trying to control or have some
learning around and when we stayed
focused on the mathematical practices we
saw the mathematical practices happening
in ways we had not seen before in our
traditional classrooms and we're excited
about that I think that we're hiccups
along the way like maybe they weren't
catching on the languages facet one time
maybe than others etc but we didn't let
that distract us it was still about are
they seeing equivalents are they seeing
structure is it happening and how do we
know that we're seeing it and what does
it look like and what does it tell us
about going to our next step and that
part we were very very encouraged it
encouraged it enough to take the step we
have this year to create a course and
moving to the next level so students now
are maybe not by working about Wolfram
language all day long for all students
but they get a deep deep
involvement with it in our course you
know so that's our time if you're
interested in having other conversations
we'd love to talk to you so you just
come grab us during the conference
please and thank you again so much for
being here we thank you for being here
[Applause]